you were building a product and you know
it's going to be great but how will you
get that product into the hands of the
right users in the right way at the
right time marketing but marketing is a
huge playing field so how do you choose
the right strategies and the right tools
and how do you know whether your
campaigns are succeeding if you do it
right this should start long before you
prototype a code check out the product
marketing course developed by Google and
Udacity to learn why marketing is more
than just broadcasting your messages to
the masses you'll also learn what they
don't teach you in marketing 101 such as
how to prepare for launch day how to
build a following both online and
offline and how to measure track and
optimize data learn from experts such as
Geoffrey a more of crossing the chasm
and Steve check co-founder of YouTube
this course is packed with practical
advice from the experts and you will
learn marketing research planning
execution and most importantly how to
grow your user base start creating today
for more information visit
udacity.com/google